let's say we're going to trace out a
curve where our x-coordinate and our
y-coordinate that they're each defined
by or they're functions of a third
parameter t
so we could say that x is a function of
t and we could also say that y is a
function of t
if this notion is completely unfamiliar
to you i encourage you to review the
videos on parametric equations on khan
academy
but we're going to think about and i'm
going to talk about it in generalities
in this video in future videos we're
going to be dealing with more concrete
examples
but we're going to think about what is
the path that is traced out from when t
is equal to a
so this is where we are when t is equal
to a so in this case this point would be
x of a
comma
y
of a that's this point and then as we
increase from t equals a to t is equal
to b
so our curve might do something like
this
so this is when t is equal to b
t is equal to b so this point right over
here is x of b
comma y of b
let's think about how do we figure out
the length of this actual curve this
actual arc length from t equals a to t
equals b
well to think about that we're going to
zoom in and think about what happens
when we have a very small change in t
so very small change in t let's say
we're starting at this point right over
here and we have a very small change in
t so we go from this point to let's say
this point
over that very small change in t it
actually would be much smaller than this
but if i drew it any smaller you would
have trouble seeing it so let's say that
that is our very small change in in our
path in our arc that we are traveling
and so we want to find this length
well we could break it down into how far
we've moved in the x direction and how
far we've moved in the y direction
so in the x direction
the x direction right over here we would
have moved a very small change in x and
what would that be equal to well that
would be the rate of change with which
we are changing with respect to t with
which with which x is changing with
respect to t
times our very small change in t
and this is a little hand wavy i'm using
differential notation and i'm
conceptually using the idea of a
differential as an infinitesimally small
change in that variable
but this and so this isn't a formal
proof but it's to give us the intuition
for how we derive arc length when we're
dealing with parametric equations
so
this will hopefully make conceptual
sense that this is our dx in fact we
could even write it this way dx dt
that's the same thing as x prime of t
times dt
and then our change in y is going to be
the same idea
our change in y are infinitesimally
small change in y when we have an
infinitesimally small change in t well
you could view that as your rate of
change of y with respect to t
times your change in t your very small
change in t which is going to be equal
to we could write that as y prime
of t
dt
now based on this what would be the
length of our infinitesimally small arc
length right over here
well that we could just use the
pythagorean theorem
that is going to be the square root of
that's the hypotenuse of this right
triangle right over here so it's going
to be the square root of this squared
plus this squared so it is the square
root of i'm going to give myself a
little bit more space here because i
think i'm going to use a lot of it
so the stuff in blue squared dx squared
we could rewrite that as
x prime
of t
dt
squared
plus this squared which is
y prime of t
dt squared
and now let's just try to simplify this
a little bit remember this is this
infinitesimally small arc length right
over here
so we can actually factor out a dt
squared it's a term in both of these and
so we can rewrite this as
let me
so i can rewrite this
my big radical sign so i'm going to
factor out
a dt squared here so we could write this
as dt
squared times
x prime of t
squared plus
plus
y prime of t
squared and then to be clear this is
being multiplied by all of this stuff
right over there
well now we can actually if we have this
dt squared under the radical we can take
it out and so we will have a dt and so
this is all going to be equal to
the square root of so the stuff that's
still under the radical is going to be
x
prime of t
squared
plus
y prime of t
squared
and now we took out a dt
and now we took out a dt i could have i
could have written it
right over here but i'm just writing it
on the other side we're just multiplying
the two
so this is once again just rewriting the
expression for this infinitesimally
small change in our arc length
well what's lucky for us is in calculus
we have the tools for adding up in all
of these infinitesimally small changes
that's what the definite integral does
for us so what we can do if we want to
add up that plus that plus that plus
that and remember these are
infinitesimally small changes you i'm
just showing them as not an
infinitesimal just so you can kind of
think about them but if you were to add
them all up then we're essentially
taking the integral and we're
integrating with respect to t and so
we're starting at t is equal to
a
all the way to t is equal to b
and just like that we have been able to
at least get a conceptual
get feel good conceptually for the
formula of arc length when we're dealing
with parametric equations
in the next few videos we'll actually
apply it to figure out arc lengths